[Music]
william is in wilmington north carolina
hi william how are you i'm good
um i was i've been listening to you for
a little bit
and i'm uh i guess i'm the opposite i i
i felt um i felt like your last
little rant is probably me
unfortunately i just i uh
i make about um
i just recently bought a house so i've
been rooting for like seven years
or eight years since the divorce and
i just i have three boys and i i don't
know where to start
to be honest with you about
somehow budgeting because it always
seems like i don't have
any money so i don't know what i don't
know where to start
i'm not familiar with the program um
and it's a little overwhelming yeah
that's fair
that's fair how old are you man
49 the subject money is so big and so
complicated uh it's like the
old african proverb how do you eat an
elephant it's so big
exactly you know where do i start uh and
the answer is a bite at a time
the good news for you is is that from 30
years of not only doing this
ourselves but teaching other people to
do it we have a map
through the bites and what to do
and we call them the baby steps and um
and there's nuances and sidebars and
rabbit holes you can go down but
basically there's seven steps that
you'll go through between where you are
today
and becoming very wealthy and they're
very clear and very easy to understand
that's good news
bad news is they're easy to understand
but they're hard to do because it's
about controlling the guy in your mirror
and uh i don't know about you uh william
but he's my problem
he's mine if i can get that guy to
behave he can do a lot of stuff right
and be skinny and rich yes sir and so um
you know
that's the deal so that that's the thing
is personal finance is 80
behavior it's only 20 head knowledge so
i can walk you through the basics
the first thing i want you to do is i'm
going to put you into
ramsey plus for a year which includes
our class financial peace university
it includes ask a coach it includes a
tracker through the baby steps and it
includes
the world's best budgeting app called
every dollar
and that's where you're gonna start
you're gonna start with a budget
okay now budget is not a theory a
budget's not a theory it's the map to
the party
and if you don't follow the map to the
party you don't get to the party
right right so you can't make up your
own freaking map
you can't turn left on the wrong exit
and drive 100 100 miles you will not get
to the party
so you have to remember when you're a
little kid and you used to say you're
not the boss of me
yes sir your the budget is not the boss
of you until you get it done
once you've designed it and told your
money what to do
then it's the boss of you it's gonna you
told it what to do and you built it now
you gotta stick to it is the point
so all the budget is is every dollar
that's why we call the budgeting app
every dollar every dollar has an
assignment every dollar has a name
and when a hundred thousand dollars is
given a name an assignment each time
and you get to decide you can decide i
want to blow
50 000 of it you can do that but at
least you did it on purpose this time
you're not going to do that right but
you know at least you're doing something
on purpose
right now this is all happening to you i
want you to happen to it
so that's what the budget does and when
you lay out and you say this is my
take-home pay
and i've got two checks this month and
i'm gonna have this much money in my
account in this calendar month of
january 2021
and you lay that down on paper and then
you assign every one of those dollars
you are gonna have two experiences
number one you're gonna feel like you've
got a raise
number two you're not gonna be able to
sit down for a week because you're going
to be kicking your own butt on where
that money's been going all these years
right well the there's only the only
one thing about budgeting which
i is that i'm commission only so it
doesn't matter i don't even know you do
know you do know what january looks like
no not yet do you get paid one day after
you make the sale
no sir it's um it's it's usually uh
two weeks after the sale okay then you
have a pretty bad gun good idea what
january is gonna look like by the end of
december
we know what half of it's gonna look
like and you also know what your
pipeline looks like
right so you're not gonna be that far
off so you can still
still do it we'll show you how to do all
that i've i've grew up i've never had a
steady income
it's always been going on so
you once you got your budget going
you're making your money behave you're
going to feel like you got a raise then
the second thing is is we're going to
walk you up the baby steps
and that says any money i find in the
budget what do i do with it the first
thing is you're gonna save a thousand
dollars the second thing is
we're gonna list your debt smallest
largest and get you out of debt
everything but the house
third thing is we're gonna build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
then once that's done then you're going
to go ahead and start putting 15
of your income away for retirement if
you are currently doing retirement
you're going to temporarily stop it
until you accomplish those first three
goals
and john there's such power and a clear
path there's always a power and a clear
path
and when you find yourself at 49 and
you're making good money
and you're coming off a divorce and
you've got three little boys
that's when the the budget following
that little
that path a series of little wins can
start to bring your whole life into
focus right
and you can start cleaning up a lot of
that as you said
that mess that begins in the mirror yeah
just by following a small plan
right william there's something that
happens when you say
i could never do this i don't see a way
there's zero energy in that it makes you
tired when you say that your voice kind
of sounded tired
sounds sounds broken exhausted kind of
yeah like
hopeless right but then what happens is
when you can actually say
gosh if i did this and this and then i'd
be there
and then i'd be there and you start to
see it yeah and ho you start to see hope
it's yellow brick road each one lights
up as you walk right every time you take
a steps
follow the elevator crowd yeah i mean
there you go man so i'm mayor munchkin
here dude i'm gonna walk you through
this right
and um you know that that's the
that is the exact way it works the
proverb says hope deferred
makes the heart sick but when desire
comes it's the tree of life there you go
and when you could see the finish line
you run a half i run half marathon when
i want to run a half marathon
i can see the finish line after running
for two hours
yeah hour and 45 minutes i can see the
finish line you still have enough in
your tank to sprint you take off that's
right it's crazy
and how providential is this this young
man calls
and got to be on the on the line
listening to
another son yeah yeah talk about my 70
year old father left us this
yeah and so dude you know you got this
30 years and you're the
20 years you're that guy make it happen
you're that guy
and you can be in a completely different
setting and you hold on we're going to
give you ramsey plus for a year
free as merry christmas and you go do
everything in that
change your legacy brother do everything
that we say to do
don't change it don't fix the system
it's not broken
when we say do it you go do it and you
will have an incredible
experience and an incredible result baby
step one is a thousand dollars in the
bank
stop all investing until you get that
some people make a hundred thousand
dollars a year have never had a thousand
dollars in the bank they don't even know
what that feels like
it's all gone through every month that's
right it just goes straight through just
in and back out
only the names are changed to protect
the innocent what's the payments can i
afford the payments
yeah it just goes straight through it's
just a cycle right feel like a rat in
the wheel
and i've had people tear up to make 80
000
a year and go i can't it's just so weird
i feel so it's
a thousand dollars why am i emotional
because you've never had control
yeah you've never it's always controlled
you you've never controlled it
and when they sit down and go okay i got
a thousand dollars now what well you
list your debts smallest to largest you
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one you sell so much stuff
the kids think they're next
you get those stupid butt credit cards
out and you have plastic surgery tonight
you chop every one of them up and you
never again borrow money and bring those
three boys and let them watch you well
help to get them to help you cut the car
put them up let the legacy change today
let the transition start today light
some candles and candles and have a
ceremony that's right we're having a
plastic surgery party
tonight put an end to this crap
and get your life back